[Music]
welcome back everyone doctor strange is
here to destroy your universe this is
going to be my full marvel what if
episode 4 video obviously all about dark
doctor strange's origin story so this is
going to be a big deal i'll explain
what's going to happen with him in the
future the mcu as well too because this
all plays into what's happening in later
episodes of what if if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes this season
and we have the hawkeye episodes that
are coming up after this careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet there were so many easter
eggs and references in this too if
you're a big fan of the doctor strange
comics or you've been watching the
marvel movies there are a lot of
callbacks to earlier marvel movies
someone's destroying the universe and
this time they can't pin it all on
spider-man there were a lot of you that
thought that doctor strange was acting
kind of weird during the spider-man no
way home trailer also talk about that
while i'm talking about easter eggs from
this episode because this is obviously a
doctor strange that went completely off
the rails and it does seem like doctor
strange goes a little off the rails
during spiderman no way home but
starting with the title of the episode
what if doctor strange lost his heart
instead of his hands where christine
palmer dies in the car crash that
originally took his hands in the main
mcu timeline version of the origin story
the episode starts with that same
twilight zone inspired voice over
narration from the watcher talking about
the multiverse alternate timelines how
people making different choices create
whole new branches of alternate
realities like during the loki finale
this time though it's more about people
making bad choices as they reference
several times in the episode like in
some of the what if scenarios in some of
the episodes characters do go completely
off the rails but the ending's a little
more positive this time it's just like a
complete downer ending like everything
just goes completely to crap but the
actual beginning of the episode starts
with his silhouette staring down from
the new york city skyline watching
doctor strange driving his lamborghini
to pick up christine for a date and he
asked the question what if the alternate
choice that is made is the wrong one
even if doctor strange had good
intentions and if it wasn't clear it is
benedict cumberbatch who came back to do
the voice of doctor strange for the
episode rachel mcadams came back to do
the voice of christine benedict wong
came back as wong until the swinton came
back to do the voice of the ancient one
so pretty much the entire main cast came
back to do their voices they are champs
there was also a special cameo it was
really brief like blinking you'll miss
it so i'll point it out when we get to
that part of the episode so technically
there was another mcu actor that came
back to do their voice for the special
cameo but apparently christine likes
creme brulee i don't remember her ever
referencing that in the original doctor
strange movie i do believe that rachel
mcadams is coming back for doctor
strange multiverse of madness so i think
the idea is that we'll learn more about
her character during that movie we never
really got to see their relationship
make it that far in the main emcee
universe but i believe it's implied that
dr strange is still in love with her in
present day the same way that tony stark
was always in love with pepper potts
even though you didn't actually see them
get together right away she references
the title of the episode the theme of
the episode asking him to get to the
heart of it the date that they're on is
actually heading to a dinner in honor of
him for this medical procedure that he
just pulled off successfully they also
had this little joke about him not
understanding television shows because
she mentions the price is right and he
has no idea what she's talking about
like the price is what too busy studying
to be an amazing surgeon to watch
television the medical procedure that
she says that he did that they're
honoring him for a radical
hemispherectomy is actually a real thing
it's a very hardcore type of surgery
where half of a person's brain is either
removed or separated from the other half
it's like a major major procedure so
it's very rare but the whole idea is
that doctor strange inside the mcu is an
amazing genius level surgeon so he's one
of the few people who could pull it off
the procedure is also meant to be a
metaphor setting up the payoff at the
end of the episode with the two
different versions of doctor strange
being separated from each other as
variants doctor strange plays it fast
and loose really aggressive with a slow
truck driver trying to pass almost
getting into a wreck but saving it until
the car behind them rear-ends them and
they have the accident that kills
christine the whole sequence of events
here is also meant to be a metaphor for
the entire episode and doctor strange
himself this version dr strange being
extra aggressive impulsive taking
unnecessary risks and even though he is
usually skilled enough to handle those
risks like pull this off unforeseen
complications side effects wind up
causing him to foobar the whole thing in
this case it leads to the utter
destruction of the entire universe press
f in the chat to pay respects to his
entire reality although he did survive
at the end i will explain that too that
small protective cocoon that he's in
survives the end of the episode that's
all meant to be set up for future
episodes during her funeral scene if it
wasn't clear all these other people
standing around him at her grave are
christine's family doctor strange did
have a brother and sister in the comics
a long time ago but his sister died when
he was very young tragically and his
brother was part of this weird storyline
that marvel never really referenced
again so he's not really an mcu thing
but the idea is that in losing his heart
metaphorically he isn't humbled in the
way he was in the main mcu universe he's
the same super smart but super arrogant
person that tony stark was before he got
his origin story in the cave and changed
his ways so that's why this doctor
strange just blows through his training
super fast he's just as apt and full of
potential for power as the main mcu
doctor strange but he's got that edge to
him like no limits version of doctor
strange so connecting things to the
spider-man no way home trailer with this
version doctor strange that seems way
more arrogant than other versions that
we've seen like just saw during avengers
end game in avengers infinity war part
of what i think is going on with him is
that really as doctor strange i don't
think that it's mephisto even though
they're doing spider-man one more day's
storyline and during that it was
mephisto but the writer of doctor
strange too talked about doctor strange
as if by the time that movie rolls
around he's become a much more powerful
more arrogant version of himself so it
makes sense that he would think that
he's powerful enough to handle a spell
like changing the timeline here that
wong warns him not to use it's not that
he's gone completely dark it's just that
he's overreaching a little bit in the
way that tony stark iron man always
overreached over did things in the mcu
that's how we got to ultron so for the
early part of the episode they kind of
speed run the plot of the original
doctor strange movie up to the point
where he finds the eye of agamotto and
learns about the time stone the scene of
wong and the ancient one yelling at him
about changing time destroying reality
obviously foreshadows what happens at
the end of the episode but it's also the
same speech that they gave him in the
original doctor strange movie when he
mentions cagliostro who's lost books of
magic he uses to try and save christine
in the episode cagliostro is actually a
pretty big doctor strange character he's
originally the sorcerer in the marvel
universe who's able to use the darkhold
to achieve immortality which they kind
of referenced later in the episode in
the mcu canonically he was also one of
the earlier members of the ancient one's
order who used dark magic as well as the
ayaabaga moto in the time stone to
manipulate the timeline in the book of
coglio is mentioned during the first
doctor strange movie but he's typically
viewed as a doctor strange villain in
the comics like another dark sorcerer on
par with kaiselius and his followers
even though the way they treat the
character during this episode is a
little bit different but then they go
back to the montage and they speed run
the rest of the plot of the original
doctor strange movie and really like the
actual episode plot doesn't start till
right after the end of the doctor
strange movie like he beats dormammu
dormammu i've come to bargain become
sources supreme the ancient one dies
just like she did in the original movie
then in what would be the time between
the events of the original doctor
strange movie and his crossover with
thor in the events of thor ragnarok he
sits looking out the window pining for
christine thinking about using the time
stone until wong comes along and tells
him not to come have some tea which of
course he doesn't listen to and then he
starts to use the time stone almost the
same way that he used it during avengers
infinity war looking at alternate
timelines trying to find the one in 14
million chance where he could save
christine's life but the difference here
is that he's not just looking at
different timelines he's not just
peeping them he's actually using the
time stone to physically take himself
back in the timeline so he's fully time
traveling whereas during infinity war he
was really just speed running scanning
the different timelines looking for the
one in 14 million chance and they play
it like a complete montage of failure
like you kind of sense the way this is
going they just dress a bunch of
different alternate routes but because
it's an absolute point in time no matter
what he does she always dies in some way
i know the loki series made it seem like
the infinity stones were keys to
creating nexus events but i think the
idea here is that the rule about
absolute points in time supersedes the
loki explainer like no matter what some
events can't be changed lest the paradox
completely collapse all of reality and
you start to notice how in all these
timelines when he's trying to see
flashes of green light around the frames
which are meant to be references to the
time stone energy as if time itself is
acting to maintain christine's absolute
point in time where she dies so just to
be clear it's not he who remains kang
who's actually changing the timeline so
that she always dies he's not affecting
any of this you do kind of wonder though
when the tva would step in to try and
stop him then here's where we get to our
special cameo scene so there's one
reality where he stands her up gets
drunk at a bar instead and she still
winds up dying in what seems like a gas
explosion in her building but the new
station is w-h-i-h which they use in all
the marvel movies all the tv shows we
saw them during juan division as well
and it's leslie bibbs christine everhart
character reporting on the death she
came back to do the voice for this short
cameo scene the sad music track that's
playing while this montage of failure is
happening is music from the original
doctor strange movie then finally the
ancient one appears to him explaining
absolute points in time and how if she
had not died he would never become
sources supreme save the universe from
dormammu then gives him the same type of
warning that wong gave him earlier in
the episode that the path he's on only
leads to darkness and the end of this
reality which it does by the end of the
episode turns out she was right on the
money and she winds up attacking him to
try and save the universe but what she
does here is that she actually creates
this unique kind of nexus event getting
to the loki connection here she uses
dark magic from dormammu's dimension to
create a nexus event that splits them
into variants but allows them to coexist
in the same timeline in the same reality
whereas under normal circumstances had
she not used her magic spell they would
have just splintered off into completely
separate alternate realities one of them
goes back to the sanctum and just stays
there not using the time stone to go
back in time the other one goes on to
become dark doctor strange going into
the distant past to find cagliostro and
here's the thing he actually does find
cagliostro he kind of calls that out in
the episode like you're messing with me
please tell me you're not cagliostro
yourself and even though the person says
no my name is oh bang that's just one of
cagliostro's many names from the comics
so it really is cagliostro just messing
with him really cool connection to the
doctor strange movies as well cagliostro
is the great grandfather of baron mordo
in the comics which is why he kind of
resembles him although the reason why
his eyes are different colors are
because he kind of went through the same
version of what dark doctor strange does
later in the episode trying to change
the absolute point in time later in the
episode they have that conversation
where he talks about death being this
natural part of life and the reason why
he knows this is because he lived
through it himself like he's basically
saying that he created the books that
doctor strange is using to change the
absolute point in time because he
himself at some point in his history
lost someone that he wanted to bring
back to life but he leads him to what
seems like his ancient version of the
sanctum maybe somewhere in the region of
mesopotamia it's kind of hard to place
this just based on the architecture
originally comic book cagliostro lived
during 1000 ad and ruled over an area
inside india and then they play the same
joke about his name from the original
movie this time though is about them
making fun of his armani suit okay
sorcerer armani let's go you notice when
he finds the book on time manipulation
it has dormammu sigil in it is because
originally in the mcu cagliostro used
dark magic to power his spells but he
learns the key to obtaining all this
power to break the absolute point in
time is just by absorbing other more
powerful beings into himself absorbing
their power but they take this literally
during the episode which is why he
eventually looks like this freaky
monster with tentacles and all kinds of
different appendages and horns sticking
out the first creature that he summons
from the multiverse probably looks
familiar you probably recognize it from
what if episode one it's the exact same
creature that captain carter fought in
her universe even though she wound up
killing it during her episode you have
to remember that that's happening later
in the timeline than when this is
happening because dark doctor strange
went into the distant past but this time
he winds up losing the fight like barely
escapes with his life that's when he
gets the idea that he can't be nice
about it he just has to take power from
other creatures there are several
different montages just to let you know
how much time is going by hundreds of
years go by during all these different
encounters eventually he grows the comic
book goatee he starts wearing a darker
themed version of his comic book costume
he absorbs a garden gnome that's just a
regular gnome from the marvel universe
gnomes come from both asgard and from
this pocket dimension called otherworld
he takes his new cloak from a magical
insect creature i'm not exactly sure
which creature this is supposed to be
some of these are actually big comic
book easter eggs and some of them i
think are just unique random magical
creatures so if you think you know what
all these different creatures are just
write them below in the comments i
believe the giant mystical raven that he
absorbs is meant to be a version of
marvel's raven from the idea verse which
is like this pocket multiverse where all
the literary characters live from books
so the raven is the mythical raven from
edgar allan poe's raven poem he absorbs
what seems like one of surter's fire
dragons from his realm we saw thor fight
one during thor ragnarok the two-headed
ram that he absorbs i believe is meant
to be a version of the egyptian god amun
ra the giant skeletal being with red
horns and a cape kind of reminds me of a
version of nightmare the giant bat
creature that he takes i think is meant
to be a version of bat dragon from the
comics it appeared as a godzilla villain
when marvel published godzilla's stories
so it was a straight-up kaiju monster
the watcher notices him going off the
rails and thinks to intervene even
though he's forbidden to do so claiming
that if he were to intervene to save
this universe it would threaten the rest
of the multiverse although he never
fully explains what that means during
this episode i think we'll learn more
about what he was talking about in
future episodes like the threat to the
multiverse is a teaser that they'll pay
off in later episodes you notice that
doctor strange has grown so powerful now
absorbing all these beings that he can
sense the watcher's presence the stag he
absorbs i believe is meant to be a
version of orona who's a god who lived
during the hiborian age the conan comics
timeline and was worshiped by the stag
cult i'm not sure who this snake-like
creature is supposed to represent but
there's another giant legit snake that
reminded me of the midgard serpent which
almost appeared during avengers infinity
war in norse mythology it's also one of
loki's children but not inside the mcu
it's a little bit different in the mcu i
know that bucky is also called the white
wolf in the mcu now but this white wolf
is just meant to be a random mystical
creature from the multiverse it's not
one of the panther gods or one of the
tiger gods worshipped by the tribes of
wakanda but that would have been badass
to see dark doctor trains absorb the
panther god inside the mcu they cut to
his perspective for the last couple of
flashes here of him taking on the
characteristics of the monsters that he
absorbs so that's why he has two heads
here why he turns into this flame-like
creature because he absorbed an
elemental way he looks kind of like an
insectoid and all these other crazy
monsters then finally he's become
powerful enough to actually take some of
the hydra's power so it cuts a couple of
its tentacles off and because we're
still in the distant past it survives
into the modern era where captain carter
winds up fighting it later they reveal
hundreds of years of gone by and this
version of cagliostro chose to live out
his normal lifespan to die of old age
when doctor strange says he can use the
time stone to help him live forever
that's just a reference to comic book
cagliostro using the darkhold to become
immortal then when he references the
other doctor strange will realize that
death is a necessary thing he's only
living half a life it's him referencing
that he knew what the ancient one did
this whole time creating the nexus event
splitting them into two timeline
versions and foreshadowing the big
doctor strange versus doctor strange
fight then a psychic impression of the
ancient one comes through a tear in
reality like she says like an echo of
the original ancient one after she is
dead to warn doctor strange and explain
how she created this special kind of
nexus event using dark magic the whole
world just kind of melting away into
black goo nothingness this is basically
reality crumbling it explains that in
trying to undo christine's death this
absolute point in time the dark doctor
strange's temporal paradox will
fundamentally destroy the fabric of
reality in the universe that's supposed
to be the reason for the rule why you
cannot change absolute points in time
you also notice when good doctor strange
and wong are preparing for the fight
he's not wearing the time stone i think
that's just more in service of being
able to tell them apart when they're
fighting each other on screen later in
the episode the guardian vashanti spell
that wong creates is a big comic book
reference so the vashanti are a trio of
ultra powerful gods in the marvel
universe that act as patrons for
sorcerer's supremes who invoke their
power so in the comics doctor strange
draws most of the magic that he uses to
power his spells from the vashanti in
the mcu they try to be more scientific
about it saying that he pulls energy
from other dimensions but they do
reference the vashanti during the first
doctor strange movie then dark doctor
strange pulls good doctor strange into
his summoning circle that he's been
using to steal power from all these
different creatures and tries to win him
to his cause i love the way that this is
basically benedict cumberbatch acting
with himself like he's playing both of
these different characters but he's
having to play one of them super crazy
thus they have their full-blown wizard
battle it's a super cool fight i wish
they would have gotten this crazy during
avengers infinity war in avengers end
game with the magic battles but i'm
assuming that they will get this crazy
during doctor strange multiverse of
madness because dr strange is so much
more powerful and you have scarlet witch
with her chaos magic who is even more op
herself when they're fighting you notice
some of these spells that they're using
are the same spells from avengers
infinity war the two cloaks start
fighting each other which is awesome the
cloak of levitation versus the dark
cloak and it uses the same trick from
avengers infinity war binding his hands
so that he can't spell cast like binding
thanos hands so that he couldn't snap
the infinity gauntlet then r.i.p cloak
of levitation the cloak did nothing
wrong good doctor strange attempts the
same spell that the ancient one used
earlier to split dark doctor strange
into alternate versions but it doesn't
work the dark doctor strange tricks him
pulling him into his shadow and tries to
show him a vision of christine to
convince him which doesn't work either
love the knockdown drag out fight that
they have through their freefall but in
the end he still winds up losing and
gets absorbed by dark doctor strange who
then successfully uses his magic to
bring christine back but in doing so
destroys all of reality and the reason
why she starts turning instantly into
that same black magical goo nothingness
like everyone else melting into
nothingness is because he did bring her
back to life yes but the universe that
he brought her back to was in the
process of losing cohesion as reality
continues to crumble into nothingness he
erects that barrier around them the
watcher reiterates his message from
before not being able to intervene it
would doom the rest of the multiverse
like i said i think that's all set up
for future episodes that they'll deal
with the guardians of the multiverse the
watcher is also correct he is not a god
he's just from a race of beings that are
super powerful and when doctor strange
asks him to punish me not the world i
believe that's also meant to be set up
for the guardians of the multiverse like
his penance that he'll serve for what
he's done here destroying his reality
will be to become a guardian of the rest
of the multiverse but he's got this
protected barrier that he's erected
around them just long enough to say
goodbye to her one more time before she
disappears and you notice as the episode
goes out fades to black the barrier is
still there around him so he has
survived the destruction of his reality
like i said i do believe he'll be
crossing over with other characters in
future episodes but even though it's
meant to be a super downer ending most
if not all the marvel what if comic
stories had downer endings if you did
spot any big easter eggs in the episode
that i didn't talk about during the
video just write them below in the
comments it was a pretty solid episode i
think it's probably my favorite one so
far it's only going to get crazier from
here my full marvel what if episode 5
video will post next week it might wind
up being the killmonger iron man episode
i've got a couple more big bonus videos
that i'll be posting in the next couple
of days make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss any of that
some more spider-man videos everyone
click here for my full spider-man no way
home trailer breakdown in easter eggs
and click here to learn what's going on
with doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness in x-men crossover thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]